we were promised a non terrifying
Hedgehog and by gosh it looks like we'll
get one on October 26th a Sonic fan
accounts on Twitter posted a picture of
a standee for the upcoming film Sonic
the Hedgehog that appears to confirm the
recently leaked images of the title
characters redesigned look with genuine
assuming that the new photo of the
standee is inducted it sure looks like
somebody really did have a friend at
Paramount who managed to smuggle out
artwork featuring Sonic's new design in
contrast to the version of the speedy
blue hedgehog featured in the movies
first trailer sonic now looks much much
more videogame II a much less likely
result of some terrifyingly an ethical
genetics experiment as you can see the
look is classic Sonic from the shape of
his eyes to his gloved hands to his body
which is far less humanoid this lines
rights up with the two images that were
previously leaked one of which appears
to actually be the same image used on
the stand a and the other which shows a
character from the front another thing
the images have in common
neither of them seem likely to give you
nightmares like the L design did the
flicks director Jeff Fowler and his VFX
team going back to the drawing board
like this is unusual it's the only time
we can think of that massive fan al
crime response to her film's promotional
materials was acknowledged and the issue
corrected Fowler and his crew even
pushed back the movie's initial release
date of November 8th by several months
to allow them time to properly dial in
Sonic's look basically the team
responsible for Sonic's design got just
about everything wrong that they
possibly could have gotten wrong the
first time around those weird looking on
most human eyes that nothing like were
used to from Sonic but they're totally
spot on when compared to the teeth which
simply appeared to be a set of actual
human teeth for some mysterious reason
did anyone really want sonic to have
people tooth no but thank you for asking
the design of Sonic's body wasn't any
better
once again the animators leaned into
giving the fuzzy little guy
oddly human proportions including hands
and feet that were much smaller than
Sonic's video game look and legs I could
only be described as disturbingly buff
gotta work out year round little bro
it's part of being healthy
well the trailer made the movie itself
looked pretty fun and the promise to
returns a gonzo comic formed by Jim
Carrey fans simply couldn't get past the
fact that their beloved Hedgehog looks
so unfamiliar and off-putting and they
took to Twitter in droves to let Fowler
and company know about it to his credit
Fowler responded almost immediately and
what he had to say went a long way
toward soothing angry Sonic fans in ur
tweets the director wrote thank you for
the support and the criticism the
message is loud and clear you aren't
happy with the design and you want
changes it's going to happen
everyone at Paramount and Sega are fully
committed to making this character the
best he can be a few weeks later
Fowler announced via Twitter that the
flicker been pushed back in order to
allow him and his team quote a little
more time to make sonic just right that
was pretty much the last we'd heard of
the whole thing until those leaked
images hit the web and it's pretty
obvious that the Flex VFX artists have
been busting their butts making sure
sonic looks as video game accurate as
possible fans across Twitter breathed a
collective sigh of relief in response to
Sonic's new look and it's likely just a
matter of time before we get a new
trailer featuring the rejiggered design
and probably a winking in joke or two
about the initial designs reception that
original trailer will live on in infamy
until the heat death of the Internet
though and will serve as a timeless
example of how not to render iconic
videogame characters so that they look
like something your child is convinced
hides under their bed every night
Sonic the Hedgehog comes sprinting into
theaters on February 14th 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite things are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
you